welcome to the show so we have been
having some complexities for figuring
out exactly what should be said in this
segment because of the schedule for
filming this week and the very very long
impeachment hearings that have been
happening in the House Judiciary
Committee we are having to tape this
segment before we actually know the full
outcome and schedule of what has been
taking place so what I am saying right
now may be outdated or it may have
already happened or it may be about to
happen but I want to kind of give an
overview of what is going to happen with
what is the impeachment of Donald Trump
by the House of Representatives
currently with a Democratic majority
Thursday very very long hearings in the
House Judiciary Committee made up of 41
members in total 24 Democrats 17
Republicans that body after debating on
and on and on a variety of amendments
which of course never had an opportunity
to pass but merely served as a jumping
off point for grandstanding and for the
repetition of what at this point is very
exhausting Lee the same talking points
over and over and over again
monopolizing news television for the
entire day the House Judiciary will or
already did vote among along party lines
yes on impeachment of Donald Trump
sending the vote to the full house in
the house they will or may have already
voted basically along party lines to
impeach Donald Trump the President of
the United States now what would be
interesting and as of this filming we
don't know but that I would be curious
to see would be are there any Democratic
members of the House that vote against
impeachment or are there any Republican
members of the House that vote for the
impeachment of Donald Trump for example
we had heard at different points in time
that there's a where she for a Hawaii
congresswoman Tulsi Gabbard who at least
one point was not in favor of
impeachment
how does she vote if at all she's been
missing from a lot of votes as well are
there any
individuals that cross party lines what
then will happen is that the Senate will
have a trial and it appears as though
that is going to be in January now
everybody has different interests in how
this trial is going to go or may go the
trial will be organized by the Senate
Majority Leader remember despite the
house being taken over by Democrats in
November of 2018 sworn in January of
this year the Senate is still controlled
by Republicans and that means that the
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
gets to set a lot of the parameters and
procedure of how that impeachment trial
goes we in looking at the tentative
20/20 Senate calendar we see that
January has been left blank at least as
of this filming with the expectation
that this is when the impeachment trial
is going to take I have been asked how
long could that impeachment trial go it
could be a week to 10 days it could be
the majority of January we just don't
know yet Donald Trump has reportedly
expressed an interest in it going a very
long time he believes may be brightly
may be wrongly that a long impeachment
trial would be good for him
however presiding over the impeachment
trial will be the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court of the United States which
is of course John Roberts a conservative
justice not selected by President Donald
Trump but a conservative justice
nonetheless so then the question is what
is going to happen in the Senate and I
will give you some of the counter points
to this but the most likely scenario I
am NOT a betting man but if I were a
betting man I would imagine that it is
going to be a an acquittal of Donald
Trump in the Senate why do I say that
well so far we have seen no interest
from Republican senators to seriously
even consider the possibility of
analyzing what it is that has taken
place and being open to voting to
convict Donald Trump a priori we have
seen Republicans dismiss the case for
impeachment save you know these little
blips that we could maybe talk about
currently the numbers are against
Democrats in the sense that there are 45
Democratic senators right now there are
two independent senators bernie sanders
and angus king who caucus with democrats
and we could save that's 47 votes right
there now there is a question as to will
every you know the senate has some very
centrist or we can even call them
conservative democrats joe Manchin for
example well joe Manchin vote to convict
Donald Trump on impeachment I'm not sure
so we may even not have all 47 Democrats
to count on on the other side because
you need a two-thirds vote to convict on
impeachment two-thirds being with a
hundred senators it's 67 that means you
need to pick up twenty Republican
senators who are forget about interested
in convicting even open to that idea I
don't think they exist and let's go
through that let's go down that path now
in a couple of different ways first of
all Republican senators are just going
to do what's politically advantageous
and that means in terms of their
reelection
in terms of balancing that with
maintaining a position in Donald Trump's
good graces etc if they put their finger
to the wind and we know from polling
that nearly two-thirds of Republican
voters said not only am I not against
Trump right now there's nothing from
could even hypothetically do that would
turn me against him when two-thirds of
Republican voters 62% almost two-thirds
say that why would a Republican senator
vote to convict when Republican voters
would likely punish them for that
decision the caveat to this is that
we've heard you know a former Senator
Jeff Flake said he thinks potentially
two dozen or more I think 30 was the
number Republican senators might be
willing to convict Trump on impeachment
well who was he talking about what is he
talking about
we don't know more recently Democratic
Senator Chris Murphy from Connecticut
said that he can count them on one hand
but they exist Republicans who he
believes would be willing to convict
Donald Trump and we went through the
list always on that list is Senator
Susan Collins from Maine although
despite her vocalising sometimes some
opposition to the Republican orthodoxy
in the end she usually ends up being a
tool of perpetuating the Republican
orthodoxy
see the Brett Kavanaugh hearings being
an example of that any time we talk
about there is a Republican who might go
the other way Lisa Murkowski 's name
comes up from Alaska Mitt Romney who is
now a senator in Utah has had some
public disagreements with Donald Trump
they were friends and they had turtle
soup or whatever it was frog legs and
turtle soup then they were not friends
and from ridiculed him whatever Romney
has talked before when he when I believe
Romney was asked about Republican
congressman Justin Amash a mash I forget
how he pronounces his name Justin Amash
saying hey listen what Trump's doing is
wrong we've got to impeach Romney said I
respect what he's doing or what he's
doing is brave or courageous or
something like that but that's not for
me so even though Romney's name is being
floated as a possibility is that likely
I I don't know how Republicans get
twenty senators to say we're gonna vote
to convict so then let's carry that out
January goes by and Donald Trump is
acquitted in a Senate impeachment trial
then what Trump convicts Trump rather
campaigns on vindication does that work
certainly non acquittal despite not
necessarily being vindication because
it's going to be a party-line thing it
likely will reinvigorate some voters who
voted for Trump in 2016 are not thrilled
with Trump's performance since being
inaugurated maybe would have stayed home
probably would not vote for a Democrat
in 2020 but maybe would have just stayed
home they may say wow this guy they've
gone after this guy on Russia now they
went after him on Ukraine and he was
acquitted I've got to get out and
support him because after all this I
don't want a Democrat getting in this
guy's been through the wringer that is
likely to invigorate so that that
ideology in at least some 2016 Trump
voters then it becomes Ken Democrats use
what is obviously going to be a a priori
a non conviction by Senate Republicans
can they use that to say guys we've got
to get out and vote we we went through
the hearings we looked at the evidence
we did what we could because we control
the house but the Senate simply will not
see
reason we now need to vote it will then
be the end of January or early February
it will only be nine months from that
election we will start to have the Iowa
caucuses and then the New Hampshire
primary leading up to Super Tuesday and
all of those the timing may and I just
don't know the timing may really inspire
a lot of left wingers particularly those
who maybe have not voted because
remember half the country doesn't vote
it may inspire them to get involved and
say this can't be I've been sitting on
the sidelines I gave them the
opportunity to get this guy out with
impeachment for what he's done I need to
now go and vote in November will that
enthusiasm last for nine months I don't
know
voting enthusiasm is a fickle and
difficult to predict thing so that's my
assessment of the next what is roughly
going to be 11 months again we had to
film this before the house actually
having that full vote it may not yet
have happened when you listen to this it
may already have happened when you watch
this but we will pick this story up on
Monday we will take your phone calls I
will answer your questions and we've got
a great Friday show coming up today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a David Pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a
seven day free trial by going to blink
accom slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK
is t.com /pa que ma n